bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france a l'argent pour quelle
raison soutenez-vous à ce mouvement pour
des raisons élémentaires du maintien des
libertés individuelles de la liberté de
circuler de la liberté d'entreprendre de
la liberté de travailler de la liberté
d'aller profiter de loisirs de la
liberté que non elle vous êtes
restaurateur 1
craignez vous que ce pas sanitaire cause
en manque à gagner j'en doute r je suis
bien évidemment je suis pas certain
d'ailleurs que la question de se poser
dans ce sens la fin de telles que ça
c'est à dire que bien évidemment que ça
va créer un manque à gagner mais c'est
surtout ça va créer c'est une
catastrophe pour le commerce en tant que
tel et pour les individus en tant que
tel aussi qui conçoit restaurateurs ou
clients ou c'est juste une aberration
absolue cndd sous le motif sanitaire
on nous impose des règles qu'on n'aurait
jamais imaginé dans les pires films de
série b
c'est dramatique certains commerçants
al'inverse un appel à la vaccination
justement pour éviter un confinement
oui bien sûr les mêmes d'ailleurs
certainement qui appelait au confinement
quand il s'agissait de confinement ou
enfin voilà donc et puis quand on aura
accepté ça on va accepter encore quoi
d'autre se fait un an et demi qu'on
accepte des choses ça fait un an et demi
qu'on m'accepte des fermeture arbitraire
des choses qu'on n'aurait jamais imaginé
on a tout accepté alors moi je vous dis
très personnellement moi je n'accepte
plus et j'ai fini j'ai arrêté de jouer
voilà je souhaite une décision très
personnelle elle est plutôt partagée
dans notre collectif
les pendus qui regroupe quand même 28
mille commerçants de tous bords ou de
toutes vos activités en tout cas moi je
ne joue plus à ça c'est à dire que la
supercherie a assez duré le
totalitarisme qui s'installe et des
franchement nauséabond
il ya une différence entre l'autorité et
l'autoritarisme et leur nez dans
l'autoritarisme et mais moi
personnellement je défend ses
convictions et je n'appliquerai pas ses
directives
clairement ce qui veut dire que vous
n'allez pas contrôler le pass annie
terre à l'entrée de votre restaurant
j'ai aucun pouvoir pour le faire
j'ai aucune envie de le faire chez moi
les gens ont toujours été les bienvenus
c'est un lieu de nous on vient se
détendre un restaurant il n'a jamais été
prouvé par aucune étude digne de ce nom
en tout cas que les restaurants étaient
des lieux de contamination
d'ailleurs j'aimerais savoir pourquoi
les restaurants d'entreprises seraient
d'ailleurs exonérés du contrôle de
passes sanitaires on voit bien qu'on
marche sur la tête complètement que
cette cet alibi sanitaire ne tient plus
en tout cas moi je vous assure que je ne
le ferai pas et je me suis j'ai aucun
pouvoir pour le faire hennir aucune
envie de le faire je veux que les gens
soient libres qu'ils aillent manger au
restaurant qu'ils allaient au cinéma au
centre commercial et ce serait très bien
comme ça yves au sein de votre collectif
on vous parle de 28 mille membres est ce
que vous parlez tous d'une même voix ou
est-ce que les avis divergent
bah écoutez moi le jeu je veux
essentiellement on parle d'une même voix
les bien sûr qu' on n'est pas des
illuminés
on n'est pas des complotistes on est
juste des gens normaux qui ont conservé
leurs capacités de discernement de
réflexion d' analyse le recul on a un an
et demi de recul sur cette maladie qui
fait 99,95 au moins pour cent de
survivants en comptant tous ceux qui
sont morts d'autres choses
donc s'il ya un moment où ça va bien
faut arrêter juste qu'il faut regarder
les choses qu'on a sous les yeux
donc oui on est dans notre collectif
essentiellement la grande majorité
partage cet avis et je peux vous dire
qu'on est submergé depuis lundi d'appel
de commerçants de toute activité qui
sont en panique parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas ce qui est en train de
leur tomber dessus et qui veulent
absolument se soulever et résister à ça
parce que c'est une grave grave grave
atteinte à la démocratie à la liberté
avec un grand réel et c'est
insupportable
on ira jusqu'au bout on fera toutes les
procédures judiciaires on a déjà engagé
des choses
mais je vous assure on est bon on n'est
pas près de s'arrêter comptez sur moi
que chacun nous rejoigne
on a des actions qui sont en cours et
qui sont en train d'augmenter et
vraiment on va pas se laisser faire
c'est impossible de se laisser faire
justement n'avez vous pas peur de subir
une fermeture administrative si vous
n'appliquez pas les directives du
gouvernement
eh bien écoutez on verra bien on verra
bien j'ai moi je prends le risque et
d'autres vont reprendre et puis on va
voir comment ça va s'appliquer ces
conditions on va voir les queues de
combien de kilomètres de queue il va y
avoir à l'entrée des centres commerciaux
il faut se mettre en situation comment
ça va se passer dans tout ça comment ça
se passait en la grande brasserie dans
les grands cafés comment ça va être
contrôlée qui va contrôler qui va venir
nous demander sur d'après notre contrôle
des policiers qui eux n'ont pas la seule
obligation d'être vaccinés du coup ils
sont interdits de rentrer chez nous
comment ça se passe si il ya tellement
d'incohérences donc oui bien sûr on va
prendre le risque
et puis si on est nombreux à prendre ce
risque est bien ma foi et quelques
comment ça va se passer
ils vont reculer ils n'auront pas le
choix de reculer parce qu'il ya un
moment on est quand même dans une comme
on dit une démocratie paraît-il donc
c'est la démocratie c'est le peuple par
le peuple et pour le peuple
on va voir donc le chacun a retrouvé le
bon sens le bon sens paysan vous savez
c'est simple c'est les choses simples
voilà il très simple donc non on va pas
accepter ça comme ça jamais christophe
chira merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions vous êtes restaurateur
nombreux venu collectif nippon dit merci
d'avoir été en direct sur arte france